多分これだと思うんだけどなぁ
なにー
えー待ってほんとに怖いほんとに怖い
うわー待って
うわぁ　あぁ　あぁ…
うわああああああああ待ったあああああ
うわぁやばい
ｱ"ｱ"ｱ"ｱ"
こんなリアルとは思ってなかった
うわっ　ごめんよーっと
はい、というわけで
ちょっとこの子がかわいそうだったので
友達を作ってあげようかなと思って
えー海外から取り寄せました
史上最強に怖い
ダメだ自分で立てないのね
なにこれ？
♩〜(オルゴール)
オルゴール付きでした
この子の友達の
海外から取り寄せました
値段がめっちゃ高かったんすよね
4万円ぐらいしたはずです
いや…
ちょっとお尻触るね〜
普通にねぇなんか
鳥肌が立ちますね
いやーこれで多分この子も退屈しないと思うんですね
チュチュチュ
これぞ…
はいというわけでこのカロリーヌちゃんを使って
若干顔色が悪いんで
やっぱいきなりこの子がいると
怖いなーって思うんですよ
プラスオルゴールが鳴るので
もうなんかホラードッキリは
もうこの子に任せちゃしょうか(笑)なと思いまして
今日はちょっとカロリーヌちゃんと一緒に
ドッキリをかけていきたいと思います
では行ってきます
はじめ）やぁ
だいち）えっ？
はじめ）まぁまぁ
だいち）これじゃないす？
はじめ）うん？ん？
だいち）だって俺、俺前も言ったけど人形かいっちゃん怖いんで
はじめ）お疲れさん今日も
だいち）お疲れ様でーす今日も
だいち）じゃまた明日
はじめ）はいよー
だいち）おやすみー
はじめ）お疲れっす
だいち）じゃーね
はじめ）はい
だいち）うわ　うわ　うわ　うわ　待って怖い
だいち）待ってダメ俺一番怖いこれダメ
はじめ）はははｗｗｗｗｗｗｗ
だいち）ダメダメいっちばん怖いこれ
はじめ）ｗｗｗｗｗ
はじめ）この子の友達を買ってあげたの
だいち）え？
だいち）え？これ置くの？
だいち）待って待ってもう一回見ていい？
はじめ）うん
だいち）え？これ、待ってこれどーすんの？
だいち）えっなっ無理無理
はじめ）今日もお疲れ様でした
だいち）お疲れ様でした
カロリーヌ）またね
だいち）え待ってなんか流れるじゃんしかも
たなっち）おーびっくりした
トントン
はじめ）大丈夫大丈夫
やふへゐ）うわぁ×6
【はじめしゃちょーエンディング】
はじめ）はっはｗｗｗｗｗ
はじめ）はははｗｗｗ
はじめ）すげーなｗｗ
やふへゐ）え、これまじ怖いすよ